[Music]
[Applause]
mariah is the latest animated film from
famed director Mamoru Hosoda known for
the girl who left through time summer
wars wolf children the boy and the beast
and of course Digimon the movie you
can't forget that in this film follows a
young four-year-old boy who's dealing
with a crisis because his parents have
just had a newborn daughter and now he
has a sister and she's getting all the
attention that he used to get he gets
very jealous and very angry and he runs
out into his garden and encounters some
sort of magical portal that allows him
to travel through time and meet members
of his family in the past and in the
future including their dog and in so
doing he learns a lesson about what it
means to be a real family and tries to
deal with this new turbulent situation
in his very young life
naturally I was looking forward to
seeing this movie because I have loved
pretty much all of this directors films
I think he's a genius I think he's a
brilliant animation director I think his
films have a lot to say they don't just
look beautiful but he clearly has
something he wants to communicate to
people and his visions are always just
so sublime and this film is no different
from the rest
another gorgeously animated tale with
very well rounded characters that feel
like they exist in the real world a
story that although it has a fantastical
undercurrent feels somehow very grounded
there are also some extremely terrifying
sequences that I could see frightening
young children but it's very realistic
in the sense that when you are young and
since this film does follow a
four-year-old boy as its main
protagonist you are frightened by things
that you know adults aren't scared by
there's aspects of childhood that seem
very frightening to you when you are
that young and this film takes those
aspects and presents some actual
terrifying imagery related to it that we
as an adult might laugh at but as a
child that might be the worst fear you
have I was fortunate enough to receive a
private screener for this movie from G
kids and I
thank them very much for that because
I'm a huge fan of this company that
screener was actually an English dub
which is very rare whenever I've been
granted access to an anime screener it's
usually the subtitled version so I
mentioned that because I can highlight
the English dub performances
particularly Rebecca Hall and John Cho
who both do a fantastic job with their
voice work in fact I'm a fan of both of
those actors and I didn't even realize
for awhile that it was them because they
really seamlessly blended with the
characters which doesn't always happen
with dubs sometimes the dubs can be a
little noticeable but this was a very
high-quality one and in particular I
must commend the young actor who plays
the boy in the film Jayden Waldman who
doesn't have many credits yet only for
listed on IMDB and he was terrific
very few movies attempt to reach their
dramatic levels that this film goes for
it doesn't hit all of them there's some
missed elements and there are aspects of
this film that feel uneven one of my
biggest issues with it is that the plot
and the idea of this garden being a
magical portal of some kind that allows
the young boy to traverse his life past
and future
at first it was unclear if this was
literal because the protagonist is a
four year old boy and so there's a very
strong chance that he's just using his
imagination and that's what it felt like
at first I actually had to go to IMDB
and read the plot synopsis that states
that a boy finds a magical portal that
allows him to travel through time and so
if that synopsis is to be believed then
what we're seeing is literal but there's
a large portion of the movie where you
just kind of feel like the boy is so
bothered by this new presence in his
life that he's using his imagination and
perhaps that might be what hosted us
going for maybe he wants the ambiguity
but the IMDB synopsis seems to state
otherwise I kind of like the idea of it
being ambiguous but as the film goes on
and he talks to his parents and he sees
photo albums with people from his family
in them and his mother states things
that they have done in the past and
those are things that we saw in
these dreamlike sequences than you
realize okay well then this must really
be happening because how else would this
four-year-old boy have this knowledge of
things from the past unless he really
experienced that through some sort of
time portal and so I kind of wished that
that was open to more interpretation and
less literal I feel like that would have
made for a stronger narrative but it
might have also pissed off people
especially young kids who are watching
the movie if it was confusing like that
still this is a film that explores
aspects of family that a lot of films
just don't really go for this young boy
experiencing things that are so much
deeper and at a level of personal
importance that he just can't comprehend
yet watching him experience that and
trying to come to terms with things that
will happen or have happened gives him a
different perspective on his parents and
on his sister because his sister older
shows up sometimes in these little
dreamlike scenarios he gets involved in
and he has to realize that hey my baby
sister ain't that bad because eventually
she's gonna be kind of cool and maybe I
should try to deal with that now and so
this is a movie that was very personal
apparently to hosted Oh from what I
understand his actual daughter is named
Uriah and he wrote the film very much so
as a sort of larger-than-life version of
some of his experiences as a youth and
so the material feels like it has more
heart behind it because it's so close to
him still it is a bit uneven at times
sometimes the journey back and forth
between time periods and then the
present doesn't always work it's
actually quite hilarious there are some
very funny sequences but I think it
would have just benefitted from a little
more certainty about what the plot was
doing early on because for a large
portion of the film I just assumed he
was using his imagination but then you
realize okay he's probably not and it
felt a bit like information was missing
sometimes to connect the past and future
and present scenes I think perhaps on a
second or even third viewing it might
improve a little bit even though this
film is
is more aimed towards younger audiences
and perhaps families it might be just a
tad too confusing for really young kids
but I feel like a young kid who
appreciates film could watch this and
and be really taken by it because it's
so magical and it is a bit challenging
and that could also be really good for
your kid you know there are some
challenging anime likes a knight on the
Galactic railroad that is in many ways a
family movie that kids could watch but
it's extremely challenging and this
could be another film like that where
you appreciate the visuals you
appreciate the acting and the story
because things that happen in the past
you hear like one specific sentence that
kind of stands out but then later you
understand why it's important and that's
a lot of narrative jump rope for hosted
Oh to get through and he does it mostly
okay I would say this is probably my
least favorite of Hostess films
excluding the Digimon movie but that's
not to say this is a bad movie it's just
that he's made such great films already
to have one that's simply good could be
disappointing for some but still I found
a lot of enjoyment watching this movie
and I think that it is good for kids to
see if they can comprehend what they're
seeing and perhaps learn something from
it I'm gonna give Mirai a be guys thank
you so much as always for watching look
forward to more reviews very soon as
always if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]
you